we understand that every day on set the
story was evolving tell us about the
collaborative process with mark and Jay
did you have a lot of input in terms of
what the characters did we did they
wrote a beautiful script that we all
were just so willing to shoot you know
like most scripts word for word and
that's not their process and they did
open the door for us to collaborate
throughout the making of the movie but
they certainly have their you know
direct specific vision and story that we
were there to serve I think you you
still get from point A to point B the
way that they wrote it but how you get
there kind of changes and evolves while
we're shooting so if we're doing
something that doesn't feel fresh or
genuine or realistic they will go on a
walk together and hash out ideas and
come back and say okay this is the new
scene and change it and and those are
actually sometimes the most fun because
you haven't thought about it and you
just act on your instinct and you just
trust that you're in the scene with
somebody a character that you already
really know in an actor that you know
and trust and you create something in
the moment and that's where lightning
strikes a lot of the time so you know we
you still get to the same place but how
you get there changes a little bit at
through the collaborative process and
steve i know you were able to throw in
some of your two cents about various
memories or maybe all of you were yeah
absolutely um you know working with them
has sort of had this
choose-your-own-adventure quality I
don't even remember those books and
elementals choose your own adventure
so we all go down one way and then mark
and J will discuss come back and then
you'll do something totally different
and then they do allow us to discover
things in scenes like for example the
the final scene of the movie where Mark
and I fight and you see me like dunking
a basketball I'm just kind of walk off
initially the what they wanted was for
me to have like this emotional breakdown
and cry on the lawn and we shot that
several times but on a different take I
just saw a basketball and then I dunked
it twice and they're like we like that
better but that was the only take that
we did this one day it happened you
can't replicate the attention that was
happening in that moment and we were all
as characters and as actors just kind of
jaw dropped because it felt so so much
more powerful than than a grown man in
crying on the lawn which you think would
be great like emotional climactic ending
to the movie but really it was just like
the aggression and the pain that you saw
in games like good yeah bombing yeah it
was more appropriate you know for the
story and you know also another
something else to mention is the editing
of these films is so important because
you know so much footage is shot and
then all this choose your own adventure
stuff does happen so an editing is very
important for Mark and Jay to work
closely with the editors to find the
right story so they have to go through a
lot of footage almost like a almost as
much footage as like a documentary would
have
so that's why they're editing process
usually does take longer than normal
right normal phones yes Jay doobie and
that Sanders for the editors on this and
I think that they should probably get
writing credits as well never really
carve out the story for us too so when
they were like going for their walks
from the guys are going for the walk oh
yeah they will no longer the walk the
more we would be sweating it out if you
don't know if it's to go yeah buddy make
sure okay we can handle whatever they
come back how do you feeling what do you
think the idea yeah everything's fine
yeah yeah but they're so mark a day or
so encouraging and supportive that they
come back it's not you guys us we suck
like we wrote a terrible seem and you
guys gave us the idea you know they
always make you feel really really
confident and supported on set and then
came an exciting thing what are they
gonna come back with what we get to do
now you know this is gonna be dramatic
or comedic after all he's just fun
process
you